[Musik]
das und pflegepersonal vom spitalbett
sich auf schwierige situationen vor
jeder da können wir patienten von corona
virus schwer betroffen sie moritz ihr
fett aber fiel anders aus sie ihr profil
max pflegepersonal und ärzte jeden tag
zum maximum ist sich wie im krieg
ob man vielleicht war der 200 der wärme
welche behandlung über hunt das ist
schlicht haben eines spitals meter statt
mit der korona krise konfrontiert ist es
ist schlicht vom kampf um spitalpersonal
wo soviel franken wie möglich vertreter
der geschichte oder mitte märz noch nie
jemand kennt neo 64 später im kanton
waadt wo corona patienten behandelte
patienten nehmen stark zu
am wochenende vom 21 22
märz von 12 neue corona felder zu was
sie zahlen und die verantwortung habe
unruhige malerischen alle karten der
satzung schon mal der epidemie mit dem
handy news erreichte trotzdem auch die
ist er schnell aufstieg von der anzahl
infizierter sorgen
musik musik über musik
wenn das wirklich vor exponentiell
zunimmt bei den hier sehr schnell ganz
viele patienten auf der intensivstation
lange wird sich schnell anstiegs klein
zu bringen
warum konnte der exponentiell und obama
damals
nur saß die notfall koordinatorin perrin
holzwarth und pflegefachfrauen ebay
plane die ganzen abläufe corona station
vom spital
sie rechnen damit dass personal wieder
lange zum start wird gefoult und dadurch
rossi fuhr ohne und die bilder krise
mir könnte für uns dass man erst am
anfang für eure krise stehen wir an den
strengen winter und personal ist
eigentlich schon wird der höhepunkt vor
der krise und wahrscheinlich erst im mai
oder im juni befindet sich in einem
container vor dem spital wo damit die
märz erspart sie das paar tage steht
patienten müsse doch erwarte man einen
trabi ja kürzlich die nummer mit
eigentlich mit ungefähr drei bis vier
personen pro tag rechnet gestoßen sagt
behandlung xi team hat sich sofort auf
die vielen zusätzlichen patienten ich
stelle mich an das konzept geändert und
sie zweitens aufteilt foyer ein ärzten
und rücklage fachfrau also auch im
respekt vor dem virus
ihre scharfe bitte spielt sich wie
andere hat stundenlang in einer person
sie war mit dem corona virus infiziert
ist wir schaffen der vorderste front und
können es darum schnell aussteigen das
tut mir im herzen gute besserung
es gibt in konsultation nach der anderen
foto gronau der mitte meines abstrich
gemacht im content über tragische froh
und nach die quote wieder zustand ist
stabil sie wird sofort behandelt die
getestete personen wider erwarten
dagegen oft ergebnis vom test vor der wm
mitte märz jeden tag um 20 prozent zu
die der krise und klimafonds und des
personals russo für notfall
koordinatorin perrin holz vor sich auch
mehrere tage mit neun bis zehn stunden
arbeit ihre sohn endlich wieder gesehen
sie holte in unserer kita ab werks
daraufhin vom medizinischen personal
offen ist wie ihre der helme tut die
alleinerziehende mutter aus dafür dass
das wirklich überrascht ich bin jeden
tag um infiziert die uno verwirklicht
das neue die mini-familie ihnen tragen
es gebe die größte mühe dass das nicht
passiert
umso mehr versucht zieht mit ihrem sohn
thomas nissen
sie weist die strecke zieht kommt erst
noch der intensivstation vom spital nie
ohne personalabbau durch monitore von
der beatmung skype entschieden nicht für
der medizinische direktor dass der
sauerstoffgehalt im blut nichts
verschenkt das ist etwas was ich stars
wollen es beunruhigend wenn dann müsste
man zu stopfen die unsere tour
[Musik]
vom 23 bis 29
märz für corona stationen vom spital mio
m2 patient der sicht einer woche bereits
am virus gestorben
und das sieht ein neues wagen selber zu
holen die intensivstation ist nur noch
ins bett frei und freundliches für den
erst patient man wusste dass jeden tag
ein bis zwei neue patienten dazu kommen
was heißt muss jetzt alle für neue
patienten wo man befürchte tätig märz
das pflegepersonal stieg druck
die vor der schlüssel person erfährt
notfall koordinatorin perrin holzwarth
ihre posten verloren 0 ext woche ist die
fast pausenlose biesalski sich positive
von chroma getestet wurde und jetzt
wieder öfter helmen und auch rugby
symptomen diese schritte sind
ich kann einfach mit koch sinn verloren
das macht mir das schlechte gewissen
dass ich mit ihm jetzt muss im stich und
armin arbeitskollegen und die ansteckt
[Musik]
im riesiger juni patienten corona
station vom spital mio
die frau wird große problem stufe jedes
mal macht sich sorgen
nicht nur luft und zwei patienten
beobachtet station hier auch der
60-jährige physiotherapeutischen mitte
februar mit dem corona virus infiziert
wurde ich an sauerstoff über home und
gepflegt aber sich mit dem maße schlecht
gegangen
wirklich schlecht in der zweiten woche
habe ich gesagt dass er sterben
jetzt fiel alles steht still und das
gängige überhaupt nicht vorwärts denn
hatte wirklich angst die woche
die patientin ist schon mehr jahr zwei
wochen im spital
die sich regelrecht wohlstand wieder
verbessert hat sie bald hängen bliebe
der friedhof ist entscheidend im kampf
der virus jeder tag macht die toilette
verpflegt olivia coach zusammen mit
seinen kollegen bild vor situation
vermieter platz dafür alle corona
patienten überlegt man sich in der
letzten märzwoche als bav andere
spitäler zu verlegen
aber das ist schwierig transport von
schweren patienten ist kommt und spittal
bezirks schwyz knapp hat gesehen dass
zahl von der patienten stark großen
probleme genügend personal zu finden
steam ist jetzt trainer zusätzliche
besucher das wird ein großer fortschritt
aber aber ist der medizinische direktor
johann christa immer nur da gegenüber
dem heimtückische virus führt das auch
irgendwie hilflos
es geht immer noch das medikament okay
wie soll man retouren dumont setzte
dafür dass ich ziemlich machtlos wie das
einzige mittel ist es die patienten mit
der künstlich habe mich zu unterstützen
denn hilft dort nummern oder darunter
war auch die moderne technologie zahlen
aber mit pin oder bakterielle infektion
das antibiotikum moment alles wirkt und
so
kleber für möglichst viele patienten
retten
fotos personal vom spital mio noch
einmal eigener tag ist es voran
christian zieht zum henker in der nacht
blieb der aufbieten
perrin holzwarth ich werde dem spital
ihre arbeit sei da klang ist
koordinatorin von opfern station fragt
sie jetzt endlich von corona virus
wieder vollständig erholt es fühlt sich
gut an weiteren teil vor dem team ziehen
dass alex und sind quasi service woche
vom 30
märz bis zum 14 april machte personal
vom spital joop sonder sorge
mathematische modell auf der erfahrung
aus italien basiere sage für die zeit
des starken anstieg vor dem schweren
foul voraus so wissen die
verantwortlichen genau gehört die werler
neue patienten wird sie die krone
stationen die der patient ganz plötzlich
und spitalpersonal sich das mal vor
der patient ist übrigens notfall in rohr
wie hanke dass es ihm nicht gut geht
dass am usb atmet werde zum hammerin
david intensivstation verbracht
station vom spital mio seit letzter
woche als pflegepersonal mehrere
patienten rette die welt sie wieder frei
wurde und der so tritt zusätzliche habe
nichts klar die prof das beatmungsgerät
issues for der armee zur verfügung
gestellt wurde
mit dem quotienten von normaler
beatmungsgerät entwöhnen und sie sowie
die töne saal durch eine stufe mit an
ihre plätze speziell ist dass patienten
ohne corolla infektion gar nicht mit auf
die andere abteilung sieht demnach war
das macht der medizinische direktor
sorge ohne treffer mehr wundere durch
darüber wo all die patienten sind
epidemiologisch geht kann grund warum
sie jetzt plötzlich weniger herzinfarkt
schlaganfall und andere
lebensbedrohliche konkrete gibt mehrere
situation erlaubt droht ambulanz zum ein
patient mit dem herzstillstand hatte war
wahrscheinlich hat der patient auch die
40 stunden vorher ein herzinfarkt korb
aber nur die spital wo will gedankt hat
das geld schon wieder vorbei und dann
ist das drama passiert
ambulanz bringt die der eher stabil
woche immer wieder neue patienten die
korona station innerhalb von stunden gab
zwei neue schwere fälle zu im control
room 816 holzwarth sorgen der patienten
geht es plötzlich massiv schlechter bei
die hand in serien tiefe rohstoffkorb
man hat versucht das mit künstlichen
süßstoff kompensieren
ihr zustand ist aber weiterhin sehr
instabil
darum sind sie jetzt der intensivstation
er betreut radiologie logistikspezialist
und gebildet von den patienten was sie
da gesehen
danke carola virusinfektionen lunge sind
eigentlich rund ums herz ohne völlig
sport sie die große wiese flacke sind
typisch wie corona patienten
sie zeigen wie stark das wie rüstungen
angriff das ist ein patient wo ziemlich
schlacht ist sexy
er ist sofort auf die intensivstation
braucht und künstlich beatmet wurde mit
der ambulanz sowie trainer corona
patient es ist ein bewohner vom netzwerk
happy sagte portius er versucht die
zuständige ärztin 8 klar wer lieber
handlich der mal überhaupt noch
ihr werdet mit der familie rede und
frage wer lebens verlängern die maßnahme
wird oder nicht
die informationen sind wichtig für uns
dann moment wisse was man mit ihm selber
der alte war ich ziemlich frei wie er es
nicht so richtig was damit passiert aber
es geht ihm besser auslasten sandra
bühler befürchtet er muss vorläufig
nicht beatmet werden und toribio also
viel arbeit aber so viel öffentlich
jahren ständig wien oli glüht klatschen
ist zu dass du drehst gut und es ist
schön dass auch behörden wie sie
einschätzt
ich hoffe dass sie sich auch nach den
krisen- oder verbessere die
arbeitsbedingungen corona krise zeigt
wie wichtig die menschen für dieses ton
thets lasse sie
[Musik]